[Musique]
les ânes les ânes gressins bonsoir
madame dernière bonsoir je m'appelle
sean c'est un plaisir métier ternir
[Musique]
notre maison est superbe
un vrai don de dieu je m'attendais une
personne plus âgée
peut-être plus normal aussi
on espère que tu vas vite te sentir chez
toi dans notre présent je parie que
derick ho hé toi allez vous entendre à
merveille
et elle trouve pas ça bizarre et aux
grands de la situation
je crois qu'il faut qu'on parle là les
parties posé ça sur la table je suis
bien comme je suis monsieur dernière on
a perdu dit ricco quand il avait 13 ça a
été dur prônera dit c'est la seule chose
qui les cas il est l'heure que j'en aime
djeric offert sa première vous avez
engager une nounou pour une poupée est
ce que tu l'as trouvé
elle est merveilleuse avec dit ricco et
si mon bébé mais fait confiance à leur
box
ces missions vous ont expliqué qu elle
sur ce qui s'est passé
si jamais elle se réveille
si jamais se souvient de ce qui s'est
passé
[Musique]
servez-vous au moins
qui vous avait fait venir dans votre
demeure